[Music]
good day my name is martin this is
walter feit
i'm martin and welcome to another
episode of what's up prof
what are we discussing today walter well
today we're discussing gnosticism and
the word of god
well for that we'll definitely need to
pray absolutely let's open with the word
our heavenly father thank you for
bringing us together again
lord this is very important subject and
it touches a lot of
important decisions to make we ask that
you enlighten our minds and also guide
this discussion in jesus name amen amen
now
why are we talking about gnosticism and
the word of god
well martin
there are so many things
that are happening in the world
and so many interpretations
of the scriptures
and so many winds of doctrine
blowing in in the world even within the
church
that if we could get the basis right
many of these problems would just
disappear
and you know that we already have a
signature tune
the bible and the spirit of prophecy the
law and the testimony and uh i think
we'll just continue having that as a
refrain verse because this is really
what it's all about it is and like we've
also stated
then it is important imperative to have
the right law the right word the right
torah
and the right word of god let's have a
look at this again so gnosticism and the
word of god
now if we turn to first timothy chapter
6 verse 20 it says o timothy
keep that which is committed to thy
trust
avoiding profane and vain babblings and
oppositions of science
the word the gnosis
falsely so-called
now
this is a very broad word
so if we look up theirs what does the
word nasus there mean the definition
knowledge
signifies in general intelligence
understanding
the general knowledge of christian
religion the deeper more perfect and
enlarged knowledge of this religion
such as belongs to the more advanced
i find that one very interesting so we
have this these echelons
of
people that are in the know and those
that belong to the
the catechumens that still have to
learn the very basics
especially of things lawful and unlawful
for christians moral wisdom such as seen
in right living etc
now we've seen that catholicism has a
whole set of rules
that are based on
their
superior knowledge this elevated
position as pope benedict said from
which they survey the landscape and as
such everybody should bow
to their superior understanding this is
very much where gnosis comes in but more
enlightened correct and in in many many
religions you have two levels
you have the esoteric and the exoteric
and the esoteric knowledge is for the
enlightened ones it's not for
the general populace and this kind of
thinking doesn't only permeate the
church
it is a very essential part of secret
societies such as freemason
and they guard their secrets with oaths
and
swear the most horrendous things
and uh sometimes you actually see these
executions where you find people that
have been hanged at the bottom of
bridges
with their
pants rolled up in the typical masonic
fashion you know like happened to some
vatican bankers etc
so this kind of thinking is
something that is very pervasive
and unfortunately it can creep into
places where it has no right to be yes
as well
now gnosticism has its roots
in the doctrine of the serpent yeah and
we've discussed this many times so we'll
just briefly
go to that verse again genesis 3 verse 5
for god doth know that in the day ye eat
thereof
then your eyes shall be opened and ye
shall be as god's knowing good and evil
i mean we've had whole discussions on it
so we won't go into great detail
but if we look at
worldhistory.org their definition
of gnosticism gets to be quite
interesting
it is the belief that human beings
contain a piece of god the highest good
or divine spark within themselves that's
the doctrine of the serpent right yes
which has fallen from the immaterial
world into the bodies of humans
all physical matter is subject to decay
rotting and death
those bodies and the material world
created by an inferior being
are therefore evil
trapped in the material world but
ignorance of its status the pieces of
god require knowledge or gnosis
to inform them of their true status
that knowledge must come from outside
the material world
and the agent who brings it is the
savior or redeemer
now martin this is a classic reversal
the one who brings this knowledge of
your true status that you are actually
divine
is the one who spoke here in the
beginning and said you shall be as gods
once you have
this knowledge once your eyes have been
opened
once you have the superior esoteric
knowledge
and then it continues and says
during the first three centuries of
christianity
there was no central authority until
after the conversion of
roman emperor constantine the great in
312 ce
now as we all know
the so-called
gift of constantine to the roman
catholic church
was the proclamation that they were to
be the superior guardians
of all
knowledge and authority which of course
was a fake
christian communities taught many
different views
in the second century ce
some groups now collectively referred to
as gnostic christians
claimed to have access to secret
knowledge
about the nature of the universe and the
nature of christ and what his appearance
on earth meant to believers
in the middle of the second century ce
a group of christian leaders
retroactively referred to as the church
fathers justin martyr irenaeus
tertullian and others
wrote volumes against these gnostic
christians
so this battle raged from a very early
time
and
with constantine
he they already started with eusebius
to get him to write
by the bible according to this gnostic
philosophy
eusebius was a great flatterer of
constantine and he was a student of
oregon and oregon was a gnostic
so oregon was steeped in this greek
philosophy as we will see
and this has nothing to do with
christianity you know if you believe
that you are divine
then you believe what satan believe
that is why it is essential for satan
to have christ if he is a divine being
to be
generated yes to be a created being
so then that divinity could just as well
apply to anyone else
in that regard
and so his war was against christ
and therefore
there is no real beginning in this way
of thinking
now the bible is very clear in genesis
chapter one it says in the beginning
god yeah
so the bible tells us there is a creator
and there is a creation
gnosticism
confuses this issue
perverts it and that's why evolution
fits in with gnosticism yes even
evolution doesn't have a beginning it
has a big bang
[Music]
but the big bang comes from a previous
big bang from a previous big bang there
really is no beginning and most of the
esoteric religions in the world
have this concept
of cycles like reincarnation for example
and all of these things they all have
elements of gnosticism
and the medici family
that produced the popes
the ones even that martin luther had to
contend with they were actually gnostic
so when eusebius produced a a bible as
it were
that could serve as an economical basis
to bring the whole of humanity together
apparently he produced a number of
copies
and some of these copies of course ended
up in the vatican library and the most
famous one is the codex vaticanus
which is probably a relic of
that document that was originally
produced by eusebius
jerome then later as we will see later
produced the latin version the vulgate
and this became the flagship of rome
the vaticanus document apparently got
lost within the library and lay there
for centuries
for a useful time when it could be
used once again
it was a document that had many
omissions out of the bible it didn't
have the first pass of genesis didn't
have the last part of the bible there
were many alterations but this is the
flagship monument
of the translators of today
now that was found just in time for
countering the reformation bibles but
we'll get to that later
and so rome claims
that it has access to the most ancient
documents
on which to base their version of
scripture now when we trace that back
all the way to gnosticism then you have
many many nuances and insertions of
agnostic nature and if you read what the
occult world says about it
blavatsky for example
says that the modern versions which are
based on the west cotton heart text
could only have been produced by a
cabalist
in other words someone with this
esoteric knowledge
and
then she she explains
that the rewriting by changing a word
here and changing a word there will give
a totally different meaning to what the
scriptures are actually
saying
more in line with gnostic thinking
now
this argument as to who was the
custodian
of the manuscripts that gave rise to our
bibles is a is an argument that has been
raging now for centuries
and of course rome claims that it
was the one
that gave humanity the true scriptures
but
is this really the case or is this uh
well
i it can't be the case
because why would the bible then warn
against rome the whole time and then
they produce the word
exactly there's something
there's something very strange regarding
this thing so when we study
where the manuscripts come from there
are two lines of manuscripts right it's
the western line
with all the manuscripts like the
vaticanus and the syneticus and all of
those and a few ankyls that are in in
that line which they claim are the
originals or closest to the autographs
the original bibles and then you have
the great
volume of manuscripts that come out of
the church out of the east
which is where antioch was
so these two lines of manuscripts
are basically
in juxtaposition they are contradicting
each other in many many places
and the question is
which line do you now follow or not now
the spirit of prophecy is very clear
that the line that
really was the custodian
came via the apostles
via the church of the east
and was maintained by the valdez's so we
need to look at the history of the
valdenas because this is very important
yeah and it's also a very very
controversial history very controversial
and we must also bear in mind
that rome is an expert at changing
history oh definitely
so when you want to read about let's say
the ruli the vandals the ostrogoths any
one of those nations that had been
eradicated there is no history it's been
destroyed
because the only history we have is that
that was invented by rome that's it they
have a very good history of burning
books and
destroying history correct any case
now
whenever we read history that comes only
from that stable
then you must be pretty sure that you
have to put on a very special pair of
glasses
to ascertain whether there's any truth
in it if you just take the history of
the reformation
how that has been altered and how
encyclopedias have been rewritten etc
then it becomes a very moot point
maybe it's just important to note that
all the history that they rewrite is
always in favor of them
always in favor of them and their
manuscript
all right so let's have a look at
this issue of the valdanzas for many
years the catholic church has taught
that the valdanzas had their start in
the 12th century
so if we read some of their quotes this
one comes from the brothers of mary
history of the catholic church for
catholic parochial and high schools
and it says the heresy of the valdenzus
dates from the 12th century
it was originated by valdez
a rich merchant of lyon
okay
here's another source the catholic
encyclopedia
the real founder of the sect was a
wealthy merchant of lyon
who in the early documents is called
valdez
valdo
as they were mainly recruited amongst
circles not only devoid of theological
training
but also lacking generally in education
it was inevitable that error should mar
their teaching
and just as inevitable that in
consequence ecclesiastical authorities
should put a stop to their evangelistic
work
this is one of those blatant arrogant
statements from
roman catholicism
and their pens
among the doctrinal errors which they
propagated was the denial of purgatory
and of indulgences
and prayer for the dead
now
then we are similar heretics martin i at
least i'm very proud to be a similar
heretic because nowhere in the word of
god do you find any of this
so here you have this typical
theological arrogance yes that
higher
understanding type of hurricane it's a
form of gnosticism exactly so when these
people
claim that they have the superior
knowledge and theological training well
if you have to have theological training
to find purgatory in the bible or
indulgences or prayer for the dead you
have to be an inventive genius
that's the thing because it's not there
right yeah
so this is typically
the way in which they think
now imagine when they rewrite history
like that
then it is possible that some people
start believing this history without
due diligence of
research to prove otherwise right
so even within our own ranks this
sentiment was echoed in an article in
ministry magazine
where they insinuate that the statements
in the great controversy regarding the
valdenzus are incorrect
no more than insinuate they're blatantly
stated
historical documents clearly show that
the valdenzus did not exist for a
thousand years as ellen white asserted
so they deny the spirit of prophecy here
right straight that's not even
they flourished from 1170 and ceased to
exist in 1532.
so again they they're using the 12th
century argument
when they merged with another christian
group furthermore contrary to her claim
there is no historical record of the
valdensian sabbath keeping in their own
documents they clearly refer to
worshipping on sunday
this comes from ministry magazine
february 2000
now if sentiments like that are allowed
to circulate in the realms of
the theologians
then this undermines the veracity of the
spirit of prophecy to the law and to the
testimony that is our verse isn't it and
from here on it can only be a slippery
slope it can only get worse right now is
this really so or is it not so
well here's an article from pierre alex
some remarks upon ecclesiastical history
of the ancient churches of piedmont and
it says
that god preserved his word in the
valley of piedmont
reneres sacco an officer of the
inquisition conceded
that it the valdenzus
is the sec that is the longest standing
of any for some say it has been
continued down ever since the time of
pope sylvester
335 a.d and others ever since that of
the apostles so here's a historic source
that directly contradicts what rome is
saying
and what we just read in ministry
magazine so this totally disproves that
argument
here's another one emilio comba history
of the valdanzas of italy from the
origin to the reformation i have seen
layman who knew almost the entire
gospels of saint matthew and saint luke
especially the discourses of our lord so
that would could hardly quote a word
without their being able to continue
from memory
yet another example this time it is an
austrian peasant
i have seen and heard says the
inquisitor who narrates the fact
a peasant who knew by heart the whole
book of job word for word and i have
known others who knew the new testament
perfectly
samartin these
illiterate peasants
uneducated knew more than the
theologians right
and like tyndall said to the pope i will
cause a ploughman
to
know more about the bible
than you and your whole set of cronies
together right
so this kind of argument that we find
so often today oh he's not a theologian
he has no right to comment on this issue
they would even get rid of jesus right
exactly that's what happened that's
exactly what happened because they argue
like that it is an ecclesiastical
superiority
which smacks of such arrogance that it's
not worth even mentioning
so let's read what the great controversy
had to say so again we have the thinking
of some theologians
and
the spirit of prophecy
the faith which for many centuries was
held and taught by the valdensian
christians was in marked contrast to the
false doctrines put forth from rome
religious belief was founded upon the
written word of god the true system of
christianity
but those humble peasants
in their obscure retreats shut away from
the world and bound to daily toil among
their flocks and their vineyards had not
themselves arrived at the truth in
opposition to the dogmas and heresies of
the apostate church
theirs was not a faith newly received
this is very important exactly it's not
they didn't think this up no
their religious belief was their
inheritance from their fathers they
contended for the faith of the apostolic
church the faith which was once
delivered to the saints and in this
amazing statement
the church in the wilderness and not the
proud hierarchy enthroned in the world's
great capital was the true church of
christ the guardian of the treasures of
truth which god has committed to his
people to be given to the world
so according to the statement who were
the true custodians of the word of god
the world indians the valdez's
so here we have two clashing ideologies
and today if you want to be in harmony
with world thinking i'm afraid you could
end up on the wrong side of this
argument unfortunately so you're going
to look like a fool in the world's eyes
but
you will
actually have the truth on your side if
you decide to go against it it's the
same with everything it's the same with
the evolution theory
right
you're either on the one side of the
argument or on the other side of the
argument
now the statement that we read that they
didn't keep the sabbath if you go to the
historical sources they definitely did
keep the sabbath
but some people will read what they want
to read and not what they should be
reading right
yeah so here's another statement
in lombardy which was the principal
residence of the italian heretics they
sprung up a singular sect
they had the utmost aversion to the
dominion and discipline of the church of
rome
observance of the law of moses in
everything except the offerings and
sacrifices abstained from those meats
the use of which was prohibited under
the mosaic economy and celebrated the
jewish sabbath
this comes from an ecclesiastical
history ancient and modern
somatin there are sources that say that
they kept the sabbath right there's
actually there's a lot of sources
there's older than this there's from the
1600s
many other sources so it depends what
you want to read and what you want to
convey and what your mindset is
i've come to the conclusion
that if we stick to
the bible and the testimony
then we will be on a sure path
and a lot of times
when you stick to the bible
and the spirit of prophecy
sometimes
depending on what version you're using
of the bible you're going to see that
there's some there's something not nice
here there's some discrepancies yes
and then you'll have to go and see if
you are using a bible that's based on
the correct manuscripts correct this
argument is going to continue
until the end right
but if you are if you are rooted in in
this in the
testimonies and you are rooted in the
word of god
then the two have to be in harmony and
where they are not in harmony that
should give you a serious clue yeah
here's a quote from bg wilkinson truth
triumphant the valdenzus were so
thoroughly a bible people
that they kept the seventh day sabbath
as the sacred rest day for centuries two
centuries after pope gregory the first
had issued the bull against the
community of sabbath keepers in the city
of rome
now why would they issue a bull against
sabbath-keeping if they never kept the
sabbath doesn't make any sense right
so
you can you can read history and you can
read history
there's another quote from the great
controversy
the valdensis were the first
of all the peoples of europe to obtain a
translation of the holy scriptures
hundreds of years before the reformation
they possessed the bible in manuscript
in their native tongue
that's unbelievable right
they had the truth unadulterated and
this rendered them the special objects
of hatred and persecution
martin whenever you have the truth
unadulterated you will be persecuted
it's a promise that's it
they declared the church of rome to be
the apostate babylon of the apocalypse
and at the peril of their lives they
stood up to resist her corruptions
while under the pressure of long
continued persecution some compromised
their faith
little by little yielding its
distinctive principles
others held fast the truth
through ages of darkness and apostasy
they were vandans who denied the
supremacy of rome who rejected image
worship as idolatry who kept the true
sabbath under the fiercest tempest of
opposition they maintained their faith
though gashed by the silver yard spear
and scorched by the romish they
stood unflinchingly for god's word and
his honor
this conflict has been raging from the
beginning and it is not by any means
over no
it is still
raging
and it's infiltrated
everywhere yes now whether all always
faithful well the statement is very
clear no some of them
gave up their
ideologies and their distinctive beliefs
and went the way of the world
and later on yes they did give up the
sabbath
but you can still find it in history
here's an article from letters and
manuscripts now what does satan propose
to do
he proposes that he is capable of
changing this bible
these parties that fell understand all
about heaven
and that they can bring in the different
sentiments from the bible and they are
going to have a revision of it you will
see they will make revisions of the
bible
but every one of us needs to stand
intelligently on the word we cannot
afford to be careless
we must have that simplicity of
godliness that is a virtue to us we must
have it
so here again
it is essential
that we distinguish between the genuine
and the spurious
now
you can come with a thousand
translations of the bible yeah
if they are based on spurious
manuscripts they will all be
spurious no matter how beautiful
the poetry or the language within them
is
if they're not based on the right
manuscripts
if they are based on perversions if they
are based on gnosticism and gnostic
insertions
then you have a problem it's a house
built on sand
did the spirit of prophecy predict that
they would do it yes
absolutely so should we be on our god
definitely and if you want to
trace it logically
we've got from the spirit of prophecy
that the waldens were the custodians of
the true word so which manuscripts did
they have correct
it's interesting that the reformers
even those in geneve very earliest ones
used valdenzian documents
in order to produce their bibles
and of course they also used the
received text as put together by erasmus
now luther used the valdenzian bible
god works with people where they are in
life's experience and leads them along
step by step higher and higher
god does not leave them where he first
found them nor do god's people rest
contentedly to stay where god find them
you know it's interesting to me martin
that the bible says god picked us up
from the dunghill
and it's true that's true we cannot deny
it
and so it was with luther
he may have first started with the
catholic bible but when it came time for
him to produce a translation of the
bible he used the temple bible a
valdensian bible
it is an interesting fact of history
that as the reformation progressed the
reformers adopted the received text in
union with the valdenzus
the jesuit-inspired counter-reformation
adopted the latin vulgate and the
vaticanus
they never had the syneticus yet
that was to be found in 1844 in a place
where it belonged namely a dustbin
but that's a different story
so this quote comes from
ted schultz's assault on the remnant
and
it's a very interesting book that by the
way
so
gnosticism seems to me to be the root
of many of our modern bible
versions
here's a quote from albert henry newman
emmanuel of church history
in the great christological
controversies of the fourth and
following centuries alexandria and
antioch were always antagonists
alexandria represented a mystical
transcendentalism
and promoting the allegorical
interpretation of the scriptures
antioch insisting on the grammatico
historical interpretation of the
scriptures and having no sympathy with
the mystical codes of thought
now
paul taught that antioch and he wrote
to his friend timothy have nothing to do
with gnosis right yeah
nothing with the science falsely
so-called
so here you had these
scribes in the 4th century
using documents from oregon and
producing manuscripts which are now the
flagships for the modern bibles
that are being produced and west cotton
horde
of course based their document their
greek text
actually on the vaticanus which they
called an ocean of
purity you know
i don't know what what ocean he was on
but it looks more like a polluted ocean
to me but nevertheless and this let me
just put this in is all from the
alexandrian side that's from oregon was
from alexandria
correct
and
wisconsin horde were closet jesuits
there is no doubt about it just like
cardinal newman it's interesting
that this
oxford movement later when they brought
in catholicism into the church of
england again
that cardinal newman would hand out
these little tracts and the people got
suspicious and whenever they got
suspicious that he was a closet jesuit
then he would rant and rave against the
papacy and write articles about the
antichrist
and then everything simmered down and
everybody said well he can't be that bad
right
and then when the job was done he became
a catholic cardinal
here's an article from martin klein's
book thus magnified thy word above all
thy name
the early christian church had its
headquarters at antioch
not alexandria
in fact alexandria was the center of the
pagan philosophy of gnosticism
which today we would call spiritism or
occultism
interestingly
the alexandrian manuscripts are really
catholic manuscripts the two main
manuscripts from the alexandrian family
are the codex vaticanus and the codex
syneticus
the vaticanus is so named because it was
discovered in the vatican library around
just in time to counter the protestant
reformation
the codex seneticus was named for its
discovery on the traditional mount sinai
in a catholic monastery
now some people will say it's not a
catholic monastery right it's an
orthodox monastery but if you go to its
roots
it was probably a catholic monastery
exactly it started from justinian's time
so yeah there's a lot of
interesting history there now
one of the bibles martin that
they rely on very heavily is the
translation of the old hebrew bible into
greek
now that one is called the septuagint
according to
the legend let's call it the legend
there were 70 scribes that were summoned
to produce this translation and they did
it in a very very short period of time
and that's why it's called the
septuagint or the lxx which is 70. but
apparently there were 72.
yeah
there's also a controversy on that one
it's called the translation of the 70
but there were 72
correct translators now this translation
is causing much consternation
because it
totally scrambles
the dates
you find in the masoretic text for
example
and which are in harmony with the spirit
of prophecy
but the theologians love the alex x
so let's just read something here from
this book those magnified thy word above
all thy name on the septuagint because
again
the manuscripts that you read
will determine the way in which you
think
that's it the only place where we have a
record of the septuagint is in the
writings of oregon
whereas the hexapolarwe compares the
six documents and one of them is this
greek translation
that's really the only place that we
have it so it comes from oregon it was a
gnostic right so we're back to
gnosticism so let's just read this
the septuagint contains many serious
problems that we could not accept as the
faithfully preserved word of god
the majority of lxx manuscripts gives
167 as the age of methuselah at the
birth of his son lamech
the hebrew reads 187 in genesis 5 25.
however if methuselah were 167
years at the birth of lamech
lamech 188 at the birth of noah
and noah 600 at the flood as recorded in
the lxx
methuselah would have been 955
at the date of the flood
since he lived to be 969
the lifespan given in both
the lxx becomes entangled in the
absurdity of making methuselah survive
the flood by 14 years
that's interesting isn't it
the constructor of the scheme in the lxx
lengthens the chronology of the
patriarchs after the flood by
720 years
you also graduates the length of lives
of the patriarchs throughout the entire
register
both those before and after the flood
the curious result is that with the
three exceptions of enoch
canaan whose life exceeds that of his
father by only five years and rue
whose age at his death is the same as
that of his father every one of the
patriarchs from adam to abraham is made
to die a few years younger than his
father
could anything be more manifestly
artificial
so you know they call this the missing
link
because there is no evidence of this
alex x other
than what you find in the writings of
oregon and i will just maybe want to say
that if you want to base your chronology
on the lxx
i don't think it's going to be very
successful exactly and that's why we
always have this great controversy
raging about whether the earth is about
6 000 years old or whether it is up to
10 000 or any other age in between if
you stick to the bible in the spirit of
prophecy and when i say bible i'm
speaking about manuscripts that have
been accepted
as the original source and that happened
to be in harmony with the spirit of
prophecy yes
so if we continue reading it says the
septuagint the alex x is like the
missing link in evolution
everyone assumes it is there somewhere
but no one can seem to find it remember
the septuagint is supposed to be a greek
translation of the hebrew old testament
from around 250 bc
that jesus quoted from proven to be
false
on page 90 of his book by the way
when on earth however when someone
quotes to you from the septuagint today
they were actually quoting from the
syneticus and the vaticanus
4th century 80 at the earliest because
they have not found the 250 bc
manuscript it doesn't exist modern
it is the mythical predecessor to the
seneticus and vaticanus that everyone
assumes is there and no one can find it
so the catholic church capitalized on
the forged letters of aristias and its
story of the septuagint to give validity
to their corrupted greek manuscripts
making them sound as if they were copies
of the bible that jesus used
now
once you start understanding these
things then stick to that which you know
is not spurious
and that hasn't been interfered with by
higher critics
essentially the earliest septuagint is
the fifth column of oregon's hexapla
or six columned bible from circa ad245
the only really significant bc
manuscripts discovered are the dead sea
scrolls
they are certainly not considered copies
of the septuagint rather they support
the majority text
so this question is going to rage
as long as we have people that consider
the textual criticism belongs to the
group of
elites exactly and that the simple
peasants like the valdenzus have no
right to dabble
in
theology
we read in ted schultz's book assault on
the remnant in contrast to the valdez's
pure and unadulterated bible
scholars
such as helvidius and vigilantius not
only rejected jerome's latin vulgate
outright
but exposed jerome's predilection for
the textual criticism of oregon and
eusebius
so now we go back to the source again
oregon was agnostic and he changed many
of the verses to suit his gnosticism
jesus had to be degraded
we had to be uplifted
the centrality of christ the divinity of
christ all of these had to be diminished
this is the doctrine of the serpent
just as eusebius produced a rival greek
text for constantine
rival to the greek vulgate now don't
confuse the greek vulgate with the latin
vulgate they are two totally different
manuscripts
the greek vulgate comes from the eastern
family it comes from
antioch and that region
which was the basis for the early
valdensian bible so jerome produced the
latin vulgate that was the rival to the
old latin valdensian bible
which was also called the vulgate yeah
vulgar vulgate means the vulgar tongue
the tongue of the people
jerome was an admirer of just just as
eusebius was of oregon so there you have
the gnostic connection
largely through the work of these three
men the foundation was laid for rome's
bible and for most of the modern
versions that exist today
so you know when this battle raged
between
the translation of the bible that the
protestants used
martin luther used the received text
tyndall used the received text
the the writings that came out of juneau
used the received text they used the the
voldem bibles when the king james was
translated they used the received text
they used the valdensian bibles as well
to
translate these texts
rome was furious
and then you know they started saying
that rome is obviously against the bible
but rome then counted and said no no no
we're against the protestant version of
the bible
and today martin it is so saddening to
see
that many of the theologians even in our
own ranks and in our colleges favor
the documents which come out of the
stable of rome
which is totally contrary to what the
spirit of prophecy says
let's have a look at a few examples
daniel 8 verse 14. this is a very key
text
and he said unto me unto 2
300 days then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed this is probably one of the
most important texts for seventh
adventists this is the origin of
the whole movement
now if you take the modern versions
then
they change it
and they quote here like for example in
the niv said to me it will take 2
300 evenings and mornings
then the sanctuary will be reconsecrated
now there's a difference between
cleansed
and reconsecrated a vast difference
and then
the king james version translated it as
days the evening mornings
and this is very important that we
understand that the king james here is
actually
correct
in its interpretation and we'll see why
if you take the tev bible which is
basically the good news bible
it says
it stands for today's english version
i heard the other angel answer it will
continue for 1150
days
during which evening and morning
sacrifices will not be offered then the
temple will be restored
again it's similar to the reconsecrated
but they've halved the number of days
now the reason why they did that martin
because they say evening and mornings
doesn't refer to a day
as the king james has it over here
they say that refers to the evening and
the morning sacrifices so there are 2
300 evening and morning sacrifices which
would make it
1150 days that would get rid of 1844
yeah it would be gone
so is it important what manuscripts we
use
it's life and death
so this is an infusion this is a first
step that we find here in the modern
translations until you finally get to
total apostasy like in the tev
and then you get rid of it all together
now the word evening and morning
never in the bible refers to the
sacrifices
when it does refer to sacrifices then it
says the morning and the evening
never the evening and the morning the
evening and the morning always refers to
a day
like it was evening and it was morning
the first day in genesis
and those are literal days 24-hour days
so this is a deliberate perversion
which comes out of the stable of the
higher critics
which are roman influence
so
we read in ted chaltz's book in the 2300
day
prophecy we see a clear-cut promise of
the coming messiah
of his baptism his crucifixion
his inauguration of the heavenly
sanctuary
and his entrance into the most holy
place at the beginning of the
investigative judgment in 1844 now let's
just pause here for a while
if it is true that it refers to
the morning and the evening sacrifices
and that the days must then be halved to
1150 then the entire first part of the
prophecy
which refers to the messiah and
his arrival and his work would be
destroyed
so it cannot be the internal evidence
itself tells us that it cannot be
so if the date 1844 is banished from the
prophetic landscape
then the scheduled sounding of the three
angels messages with its warnings about
receiving the mark of the beast with the
sabbath sunday issue
would likewise disappear
one could never arrive at the date 1844
by using some of the modern versions
many modernist scholars reasoned that
the 2 300 days of daniel 8 14 are
actually
1150 days
since the 2300 evenings and mornings
is a reference to the evening and the
morning sacrifices
in the bible when sacrifices are
referred to the words morning and
evening are used
not evening and morning
as it is in daniel
chapter 8. now here are a few examples
ezra 3 verse 3 burnt offerings morning
and evenings there it refers to the
offerings right
ii chronicles 31 3 for the morning and
the evening burnt offerings
second chronicles 2 4 the burnt
offerings morning and evening
numbers 28 4
the lamb shout their offer in the
morning and the other shout their offer
at even
so when literal days are spoken of such
as the literal days of creation in
genesis chapter 1 the words are and the
evening and the morning were the first
day
genesis 1
5.
now in our previous discussions
i
referred to
the efforts of some theologians
to take away the emphasis of the remnant
that would arise to bring a message
after 1844 which happened to be the
three angels messages and this is one of
the ways in which they attack that
but they don't realize that they're
shooting themselves in the foot because
if they destroy the second half of the
prophecy then they also destroy the
messianic part of the prophecy at the
beginning
so the internal evidence of the bible
says that our understanding of 1844 is
absolutely spot on
and any contradiction
not only contradicts the internal
evidence of the bible it contradicts the
spirit of prophecy as well
to the law
and to the testimony if they speak not
according to this word there is no light
in
them here's another very interesting
verse martin
and uh
we read it in hebrews 9 27
and as it is appointed unto men once to
die but after this
the judgment
hebrews 9 27 i think this is the niv
justice people are destined to die once
and after that to face
judgment
now martin there's a little word missing
there and that is the word
the
which is in bold up here in the king
james version
now you know that blavatsky
said we will
just by altering a word here and then
and westcott and hart said exactly the
same thing we can change the entire
meaning of the scripture
man shall not live by bread alone but by
every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of the lord
now
that little
every word that proceeds is gone out of
the gospel of luke it's still there in
the gospel of matthew
and of course it's a quote from the old
testament
now they say well what's your problem if
it's gone there it's still in the other
one
but the bible clearly says by two or
three witnesses shall every word be
established if you remove the second
witness out of the new testament
then you have a problem right
and it's cleverly done it's very why do
you remove that one word now let's just
read
what they themselves say
how carefully
they have thought about this why did
they remove the word the
well let's ask them canon ferrar fellow
member of the apostle club
with the west got the naught that by the
way was a secret society
states that this omission was deliberate
and here's his quote in the omission of
that unauthorized little article
from the authorized version by the
revisers
lies no less doctrine than that of the
existence of an intermediate state
in other words they've inserted
purgatory into this by just removing the
word the
is that clever
it's it's
it sounds like the adversary it sounds
exactly like him and it was deliberate
so it's not a slip
so martin would you like to rely on
documents
that have such deliberate omissions or
insertions in them not at all not if my
life my eternal life is depending on
this aren't there certain admonitions in
the bible that if you touch the word of
god
then you will be in serious trouble
hebrews 1 3
is another interesting one
who being the brightness of his glory
and the express image of his person and
upholding all things by the word of his
power when he had by himself
purged our sins
sat down on the right hand of the
majesty on high that's the king james
version
now the niv the rsv the nrsv the nlt the
tev the asv the nisb the nwt the nib
omit the word by themselves
by himself
why
because that gets rid
of jesus as the soul mediator and allows
other mediators like the saints
or mary and priests or priests and popes
and prelates
so
if you go to richard foster celebration
of discipline
we were mentioning him in the previous
what's up prof as well correct and he of
course relies on the renovate bible
do you know martin that some people even
with our in our own ranks advocate that
we could benefit from reading such a
translation didn't that person tell you
that
he's just as inspired as ellen white
correct
it was you know
yes it was a conference official
he told me
that richard foster was as inspired as
alan white and remember i told him that
i agree with him but the inspiration
came from beneath and not from above
and they were very angry with me
but listen to what he says he's now
deceased
the followers of jesus christ have been
given authority to receive the
confession of sin and to forgive it in
his name
does that sound protestant or catholic
catholic
we have tried to convince ourselves that
god only
can forgive sins
it is through the voice of our brothers
and sisters that the word of forgiveness
is heard and takes root in our lives
there's a third advantage to the
institutionalized confessional namely
penance
total roman catholic doctrine
by taking out the words by himself they
have placed themselves in the position
of god
gnosticism at his best this is gnostic
this is the gnostic gospel
so when the niv the rsv the nrsv the nlt
and all of these omit these words it has
a gnostic origin and you are basically
reading
a document with gnostic elements in it
you cannot defend
any serious
doctrine
pertaining to the ministry of christ
where it is taking place
what atonement stands for
what it means to be saved from your sins
and not in your sins and
you have this entire catastrophe
as another example
colossians 1 14
in whom we have redemption through his
blood
even the forgiveness of sins
colossians 1 14
in whom we have redemption the
forgiveness of sins the niv now why
would they leave through his blood out
in fact it's not only the niv it's the
rsv the nrsv the tev the nwt the nlt the
hsv
the ed the nab the nlp they all emit the
word through his blood
because catholicism teaches that you are
not saved by the blood of the lamb you
are just saved by the good works
for which mary also qualifies or any of
the saints
you can pray to pope john paul ii he's
now saint
pope john paul ii
if you remember
trump and his wife they bowed down and
prayed
correct the altar of
pope john paul correct
but if you read lepeticus 17 11 it says
for the life of the flesh is in the
blood and i have given it to you upon
the altar to make an atonement for your
souls for it is the blood
that makes an atonement for the soul
just because rome has a inverted gospel
doesn't mean that i have to read it in
the scriptures
so is it important what manuscripts we
use definitely it's important
you you're gonna walk into a wall
pretty soon
when you're using the corrupt one i've
been on the carpet on this issue so many
times i told you in my
stories in the last whatsapps that that
was one of the reasons why i was banned
in germany right
there are literally
scores of books that have been written
on this issue
i have a whole shelf full of them in my
office
and modern i read them all
every single one of them and i read the
counter arguments as well
to be fair yeah
and i cannot believe
that our theologians or at least some of
them
would be so duped by higher criticism
and
manuscript
theology that they would rely on these
flagships of rome the vaticanus and the
syneticus and a handful of corrupt
unkills
to build an entire theology which
happens to destroy protestantism and the
advent movement exactly you cannot even
confirm some of our pillars
based if you use the new translations
correct so this is actually a serious
problem and they can argue as much as
they like
simple logic
tells you
that the manuscript source
is the one that creates the problem in
the first place and you can have a
thousand translations
based on
spurious manuscripts
and you can say this is the word of god
no not if it contradicts the rest of the
bible and the spirit of prophecy correct
we read in patriarchs and prophets
by obedience the people were to give
evidence of their faith so all who hoped
to be saved by the merits of the blood
of christ
should realize that they themselves have
something to do in securing their
salvation
by the merits of the blood of christ
this is a central pillar of salvation
while it is christ only that can redeem
us from the penalty of transgression we
are to turn from sin to obedience
you know this doctrine that we cannot
obey
makes the whole gospel obsolete when
jesus says
go and sin no more obviously then he
must have meant
go and sin some more but
as long as you feel sorry you're fine
doesn't make sense
man is to be saved by faith not by works
yet his faith must be shown by his works
god has given his son to die as a
propitiation for sin
he has manifested the light of truth the
way of life he has given facilities
ordinances and privileges
and now man must cooperate with these
saving agencies he must appreciate and
use the helps that god has provided
believe
and obey
all
the divine
requirements
to the law
and to the testimony
now here's another verse that's very
interesting
and that is daniel 7 22
and it reads until the ancient of days
came
and judgment was given to the saints of
the most high and the time came that the
saints possessed the kingdom
king james version
now modern
this is
absolutely in harmony with the internal
evidence of the bible
and with the spirit of prophecy
the new translations
like the new king james or the niv
translated as follows
until the ancient of days came and
judgment was made in favor of the saints
of the most high
and the time came for the saints to
possess the kingdom
now there's a big difference between in
favor of them
of the saints of the most high
and judgment being given to the saints
right
the niv says until the ancient of days
came and pronounced judgment in favor of
the holy people of the most high
it sounds like quarter
and the time came when they possessed
the kingdom
so you have two translations modern
translations
that
render it
differently from the king james
now let me make it quite clear people
always say you know that fight fellow is
a king james only man
no i'm a receive text only man when it
comes to the new testament and there's a
big big difference
because there are many languages in
which that received text is translated
but unfortunately then you get a
translation like the new king james
which is based on the
on the receive text
and it follows in this particular
incident
the the manuscripts of wrong
so why is this important martin
well you see the spirit of prophecy
clearly
aligns this text with what we read in
the book of revelation
where when christ comes
the books are handed over for
verification to the saints do you not
know that the saints will judge the
world says paul so she applies this to
the end of the world
whereas if you read it as the new
translation have it then it refers to
the investigation that takes place
before the coming of christ
now unfortunately
even our some of our own study bibles
that use the new king james
have it wrong
and they apply it to that investigation
and not to the coming of christ in spite
of the fact
that the spirit of prophecy
applies it to the coming of christ let's
read it
so we read here in the southern watchmen
of march 14 1905 about the millennial
judgment
during the thousand years between the
first and the second resurrection
the judgment of the wicked takes place
daniel declares that when the ancient of
days came
judgment was given to the saints of the
most high there she quotes daniel 7 22
and at this time the righteous reign as
kings and priests unto god john in the
revelation says i saw thrones and they
sat upon them
and judgment was given unto them
they shall be priests of god and of
christ and shall reign with him a
thousand years it is at this time
that as foretold by paul the saints
shall judge the world
in union with christ they judge the
wicked comparing their acts with the
statue books the bible and deciding
every case according to the deeds done
in the body satan also and evil angels
are judged by christ and his people
samartin
here again we have a prime example
of the spirit of prophecy being in
perfect harmony
with the translation as we find it on
daniel 7 22 in the king james version
and at absolute variance with the
translations in any of the others
why is it
that even some of our people
will run with the worldly translations
and deny the spirit of prophecy in the
process we cannot afford that if we want
to understand
and have unity in terms of doctrine we
need to base what we believe on the
bible
and the testimony
and this idea that you have to be a
theologian
in order to understand textual criticism
makes no sense whatsoever
because if your basis is a document that
has gnosticism in it
then no matter how you argue about the
veracity of the text it cannot be
accepted because
there is only one line
that has the stamp of approval
and we know where that line ran
it ran from the disciples through the
vuldances
and
then to the reformation
it is unthinkable
that god would give the wrong
manuscripts to base the most important
doctrines of salvation on
to the reformers
and that the
system that he claims to be the
antichrist will be the one that is the
custodian of his word it is unthinkable
i just want to bring it back it's
illogical
absolutely it's like there's a lot of
logic in what you have to think about
and if you can use your logic
you don't have to be a higher critic to
use logic correct so how important is it
that we understand
the language of the critics and that we
understand greek and hebrew
so is our knowledge of greek and latin a
requirement for interpretation now
here's a comment from the committee on
problems in bible translation
and and they wrote amazingly the problem
is how the participle and then they use
a
greek word here should be translated
with the infinitive
and then they use the greek word here
which follows
this is an
analyst construction and so is an
adverbial particle
now martin
most bible readers as tedcul says here
will not find such explanations
illuminating a veiled message that was
conveyed by the committee seemed to be
if you don't know greek you are not
qualified to try to interpret the
scripture and certainly not qualify to
judge the veracity of any version of the
bible
and this is exactly the same sentiment
that i faced every single time plain
simple
faith in the bible and the spirit of
prophecy that happened to be in harmony
in one translation and in disharmony in
another translation is not an argument
no you get arguments like this
so
if we read letters and manuscripts
volume 12
we read the following
it is a far greater consequence
that students study god's word
than that they study greek and latin
yet some may carry the study of these
languages with success especially greek
and yet not placed themselves above the
word of god
but it seems to me that many people find
it very difficult not to place
themselves above the word of god
and to accept the reasoning of higher
critics and introduce it into the very
thinking
of the remnant
my suggestion in harmony
with this latest statement
is let us stick to
the word as it is written
based on the manuscripts which god gave
to the reformers
and let us leave
gnostic writings which are based on
gnostic sentiments
to those who wish to indulge in them
and that wish to elevate themselves
ecclesiastically
above their fellow men and to set a
standard that only they can reach
and all the rest are
or catechumens
as tindal said a plowman
will know more about the scriptures than
many a pope a prelate and
a higher critic
may god preserve us
to stick to the simplicity of the word
and it is essential
that
we
unify
on this issue yes because the time is
short
yes we have to get this out of the way
that we can start giving the loud cry
how can you give the loud cry
if you do not know what the marching
orders of the remnant is if you do not
know that then you cannot be part of the
loud cry because the loud cry is
come out of her my people that you
receive not of her plagues
she has fallen she has fallen
and the third angel's messages do not
accept the mark of the beast
if you do not believe
what the bible and the spirit of
prophecy say on these issues you will
get lost in the quagmire
let's unify
on that
which the pioneers understood
which they made part of their doctrine
and which they handed as an inheritance
to god's people based on the word
and the spirit of
prophecy that is where our marching
orders lie may god give us wisdom
to unify on that which has been
established
through prayer
and study and let us not just accept it
because they said so let us verify it
for ourselves and internalize it and
then we can have a unified verse voice
for the world amen shall we pray please
heavenly father
help us to understand that you have
given special counsel for the times that
we are living in
lord if we brush it aside and run
with higher criticism
and put everything on the scale and make
many things of non-effect how can we
have unity
lord give us unity in truth
and not unity in speculation and error
is my prayer in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe to our channel click here
to get notifications click on the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again